all right david i wanted to start with
you here i know you first wrote the
script in the late 90s so it was making
me wonder what is the biggest difference
between the first draft you had written
back then compared to what we see in the
final film now um really
in terms of screenwriting no difference
i didn't change one word there was i did
one draft
um
a couple of things are different in that
i cut some scenes that were in the uh
that we did shoot
because that in a way the ed in the
editing room
that's your second draft you know so uh
they were scenes that were i saw
redundant made redundant by how the
dynamic of the of other scenes but
that's that's very common that's
very and the the only other changes are
the normal production changes for
example we're shooting in athens i had
not anticipated 20 years ago that i
would never shoot this movie in athens i
but once we were
uh we were all taking full advantage of
embracing completely athens the
mediterranean all that
uh the the texture of the city this
ancient city 3000 years old i thought of
the movie as taking place in toronto
which is a very young city by comparison
obviously
uh so but those are normal production
things that they
it's it's a lot of movie making for me
is found art you know you find something
uh that you never expected either in a
person or or an actor or
or a location and uh
and you embrace it because it's
stimulating and it's exciting and it's
unexpected so those things but in terms
of screenwriting not no changes what
about when it comes to the special
effects of it all because your work in
the body horror realm has always been
next level but are there any new tools
or techniques in that particular sector
that let you accomplish something on
crimes of the future that you never
would have imagined was possible at the
point that you first wrote the script
a lot of things a lot of things visual
effects has come along beautifully and
wonderfully and it's just an amazing
tool i mean i i of course i've used it
in the past uh even existence we created
some creatures that were completely cg
but now it's so it's relatively
inexpensive relatively quickly quick uh
uh quick to to uh manifest and to
experiment with
and uh
some of the uh
the
tools in in the in the sarc for example
we created physically
and they were puppeteered
in other scenes where we couldn't do
puppeteering
uh they are completely cg and they're
based on what we created physically
and they're so good you really cannot
tell the difference i mean it's really
quite remarkable
and and very affordable so
uh so
it allows you such freedom
in terms of the way you uh position the
cameras and what the actors can do it's
really fabulous can confirm i couldn't
tell the difference so great success in
that department thank you
all right scott so i was reading
something that you said about trusting
the words and seeing where they took you
so is there any particular scene in the
film that surprised you in that respect
where you walked onto set with one
particular idea but then the words took
you to a completely unexpected place i
mean i think like you know if you're
doing your job even remotely correctly
and anything that should be happening at
all times just like david talks about
with directing i mean to not be too
like a better way to say it precious you
got to reinvent it that day i think
that's the goal whether i'm successful
that or not that's the constant struggle
as i get older keep getting better at
that to be able to surprise yourself in
the
in the moment but probably my first
scene where i shot with viggo that one
shot we did you know where that walking
down the street we did it as a winner um
what bubbled up and what was happening
how we shot it yeah that was all
surprising and where the scene went so i
i loved so
yeah that was my favorite probably for
me just in terms of selfishly as an
actor my favorite scene in the movie
yeah scott's rhythm in that scene is
really extraordinary and very unexpected
yeah and it provoked other things from
vigo too yeah and i think we just did
one or two takes yeah yeah as well kind
of twisting that idea around a little
bit and jumping off a quote that i was
just reading from kristin she said
something to the effect of you know the
actor spends every day being like what
the [ __ ] are we doing but then you all
sat down and you watched the movie and
everything became crystal clear so scott
was there anything that you shot for the
film that had you saying you know like
what the [ __ ] am i doing on set the most
and then you saw the film and it was
above and beyond anything you could have
imagined
i mean i think yeah i mean you know to
be honest the movie to me is exactly
how i
you know would have loved for it to turn
out and watch you know because you i you
know whatever she's saying i i think i
understand what you're saying but you
immerse yourself so deeply in this world
that it ceases to be absurd or different
or futuristic or anything
and that becomes normalized it has to so
you can play the scene so watching the
movie was you know
it's a relief for what we were doing for
those six or seven weeks in greece
showing up on screen for me as an actor
where i am in my career that's just so
so amazing because that doesn't happen
all the time oftentimes there's a big
discrepancy between what you think
you're shooting and what ends up on the
screen and that's that's the great joy
of this movie for me i mean the thing
i've i've heard from many actors in fact
that they don't they say to me they
confessed to me i i really don't know
what i'm doing and i say that's great
just keep doing what you don't know
because they do know what they're doing
and kristin absolutely knew what she was
doing if unconsciously
uh
and and uh and honestly that's a little
like life isn't that i mean at any
moment in my life i can look around and
say what the [ __ ] am i doing and i have
no idea really but somehow i still
you know function so
that's just a life reality i think
kristen is expressing
and she was you know incredibly focused
and precise and fantastic at the movies
so somewhere she do what she was doing
yes without that quality life and also
movies would be quite boring and too
familiar so i think that comes from the
fact that you guys do something that i
don't think anyone's really seen put on
screen this particular way so i love
that quality of it well i love that you
say that i really do and i'm going to
quote you
please do i very much mean it um david i
was watching another interview you did
where you spoke about the value of
watching film on devices like an ipad
and i i have that argument or i should
say i have that conversation all the
time so i appreciated that uh that
stance on it and it was making me wonder
when you're making crimes of the future
are you picturing yourself making a
movie for the big screen or has that
idea completely evolved into something
new for you even as far back as shivers
and rabbit my first two sort of
commercial movies i was always
aware that more people would see it on a
intel on television than they would on a
big screen even then because you have a
release it's in the theaters after that
it's on television and so i made sure
that the because in those days the the
television screen was four by three it
was very square but we were shooting
more widescreen so i made sure that
those movies were framed in such a way
that they could be shown on television
and still not sort of deranged in terms
of the framing and the composition
so for me this is not a new thing i mean
i assume that more people are going to
see crimes of the future on their you
know apple watch
then they are going to see it in a big
theater that might be too small
but the other thing is that you don't
have to make
the thing is the the resolution and the
color balance and everything of the
devices these days compared with the old
days of black and white television for
example
it's so good that i don't have to make
any concessions in terms of composition
and so on
it works on a huge screen like the one
in can that was probably the biggest
screen we're ever going to see it on
with 24 or 2500 people watching
uh it'll absolutely look great on your
ipad i have absolutely no doubt about
that and also on your phone
you said in the interview that when you
have the ipad it feel it makes it even
more immersive because it's so close to
your face and i feel like you put it
more eloquently than i ever have but
like that's the feeling that i have
which is why i appreciate every format
of screening it's like it's like reading
a book you know you have it here it's
right here it fills your field of vision
what's the problem the resolution if the
resolution of the color and the sound
are good it's good and to me that is
still counts as a cinematic experience
you know i don't i think that that's
where
cinema is going i think that
uh theaters will be there will be fewer
of them they'll be showing there'll be
niche sort of
venues where the only specific things
maybe marvel movies only i'm not sure
will be shown there and for the rest of
us it'll be watching on our own private
screens
you